[Music]
all right welcome back to another
episode of chapelle's world
thank you guys for tuning in today yeah
uh we took a week off we had a good week
off because uh brendan's uh gringo poppy
yeah we dropped the special we wanted
you know let it let it do its thing let
it take its course if you haven't seen
it go watch it go watch it on the
dickboy channel as well as this is on
the
big boy uh
youtube channel as well
um
man i have to start with this yeah
a lot of stuff yeah i mean we got a lot
of stuff yeah we got we got a lot of
stuff like 100 things here 100 things on
there yeah oh man
because it was just the top of the
morning to see it top of the morning top
of the morning i suck at that i'm not
going to do it again you're irish right
i would love to see a black irish
you know what later on we're going to
youtube black irish well it's actually a
thing black it's not like a black guy
who's irish but black irish is like
if you're irish but have like dark hair
and like oh kind of darker features
rather than like a red-headed oh
something to do with like spanish irish
i've i don't know the details but yeah
gary casey guaranty casey jerry it is a
phrase black irish oh well i didn't know
that well now i do know black irish that
you know what that's what they call you
that's why i'm gonna say
that dude
dave chappelle
hollywood bowl what the hell last night
someone tried to take a [ __ ]
someone tried to hit him with that
[ __ ] what do you call it it's just a
regular tackle i guess this man tried to
his form was bad his form was bad
because he didn't necessarily take dave
down i don't think
i don't think he took dave
to the ground i think
the guy probably
he made an attempt bro they rushed got
him [ __ ] roughed his head was like
swollen his arms back here dude somebody
on twitter said they suggered him dude
his arm shout out to tom meanwhile
i don't know if people don't realize but
that dude can't feel that
because he if he's in the stretcher
obviously they probably gave him a shot
i don't know what the shot is called
specifically but meanwhile the thing
that drives me crazy
about people with comedy shows
it's like if you're gonna get mad
they get mad at the whole set
because a lot of times
there's a lot of different [ __ ]
comedians are making fun of
if you're gonna get mad at that part get
mad at the whole set yeah
don't just cause like it it may hit home
to you
also it doesn't about you like we don't
know
anyone that's in the audience we don't
know you
we don't know you at all
we have no idea who you are
so if we say things but that's the art
of comedy you're not supposed to say the
correct thing imagine if that's what
comedy was you're just going up there
saying
just
the correct [ __ ] that's a lecture that's
a lecture
that's a lecture in applause breaks
that's what that is but that's not what
comedy is
everyone has a right to get offended you
can get offended you can get offended
that's fair
that's fair but to
attack someone
especially comedian
that's your comedian someone that's
writing a joke to say something funny
not to
not for a malicious attack but to say
something funny
i think
i think you you're in your own way
i think there's this thing that people
need to learn like
hey people are going to say whatever the
[ __ ] they're going to say
you kind of just got to let that be
and you kind of just got to own
whatever it is about you
and let that let that be the thing i
think yeah i think it's just a crazy guy
like who gets up and tries to tackle
somebody first saying jokes and then got
stumped defucked out by busta rhymes
yeah
jamie bruh what a lucky stump out though
think about it that's a star
that's a star
jamie foxx
dave chappelle
busta rhymes
what
yo stomp me out
[Laughter]
stomp me the [ __ ] out
but let me live to tell a story let me
live to tell the story
so i could just be like hey i deserved
it
but hey
hey
i'm putting my body on ebay
put it on ebay like hey make it in there
this is the body that got stumped how
much
[Laughter]
i'll start the bidding
at thirty thousand that's fair that's
fair not too high you thought i was
gonna say like five hundred thousand no
i'm gonna give you thirty thousand to
start with
have fun
that's that's where i went
anyways great crazy to say glad
everyone's okay well except that guy
except for that guy but uh yeah man i
had to talk about that first because
that was an insane
thing to me just to
see at the top of the morning and the
top of the morning
i know
uh
yes so
i announced this on fighter and a kid i
have decided to leave
uh fighter in the kid i decided to leave
fighter and a kid
um
it's actually a feeling i've been
feeling for a really long time
uh
i
started feeling that feeling when brian
had came back
and
i remember i even called uh
brennan's brother jay
shouts out to jay schaub
he's so funny uh i called him
because i was like let me call the
closest person to brenda let me call his
brother and just talk because i wanted
to talk you know just needed to let it
out some way another but i wanted to let
it out not to some random person i
wanted to let it out to someone that
knows
you know
the circle
you know and so uh
he's like nah man just do your thing and
you're having fun i was like
all right okay so he told you to keep
doing
no that's stupid don't do that
man you think no but uh
no it's just
when when
when i think about the situation i
remember
yeah around the time brian had came back
was the talks of
um
chappelle's world
and i was excited for that and obviously
took a little bit to to get it to
where we're at right now
and
um i know i i had a great time being on
there i think i just
was just kind of checked out
and
i just really thought about how
i was like man this is their show
this ain't my show i didn't build this
show i didn't start the show
i didn't uh
you know
i didn't do any of that
they spent over a decade
building a chemistry together and doing
this thing
not saying i felt like out of place i
just i admired the fact of what they
were doing
and
they finally were able to have it back
yeah it sounds like you wanted to kind
of give it back to them yeah and not not
saying
in the least arrogant or weird way
possible not saying give it back but
it's just like man like yeah do that
yeah
do what this is yeah yeah
this is this isn't what this is the
three of us isn't what this is this
isn't fighter and the kid
finding a kid is
brennan and brian
and that's that's what i was feeling i
was feeling it for a whole time and um
[Music]
i think over time
i just kept that feeling just kept
getting stronger and stronger especially
when chappelle's world started to roll
in
i just uh
man i was like man i like doing
chappelle's world even when i'd be in
the
final kid room and doing the episode i'd
be thinking about chappelle's world and
i just say oh i can do this with it this
way i want to do this i'm going to do
this dude i just i was just kind of
checked out
and um
i just i
also felt like i was doing a lot of
podcasting right yeah on the last one
the last episode
your voice is all like this yeah yeah i
was like i'm doing a lot of talking i
also made you do two chappelle's world
in one week yeah but which is fine
but i
i'd rather that because i could give all
my focus to that
and put put a lot into it and it's
mainly because yeah i i
i'm excited about the things that i'm
doing as an individual i'm excited about
the things that i'm doing as chappelle
lacy and my time there i had a great
time it was super super fun
um
but
just over time i felt i felt like i
needed to move on it was funny because
uh
i guess my i wear my emotions pretty
clear whenever i'm feeling something
uh
and brendan had texted me
he was like hey man we cool
so he picked up on it yeah i was like
yeah why wouldn't we be this is
last week or two weeks ago when i was in
austin
and i said yeah why wouldn't we be
because i don't know i guess i just
maybe it's just anxiety or my anxiety
acting up or
just i don't know i don't know maybe
just vibes maybe it's just on me and i
was like
then i thought about that thought about
it that night because he talked to me
that that night was texting me that
night
and i was like man you know if he's
feeling something if i'm giving off some
vibe then i should say something i'm
getting off a vibe that i'm
being weird or kind of distant or
anything of that nature that i need to
say something because i was thinking
like i said i started thinking about
about it even heavier
especially after that that last step the
last chapel's world episode where i was
just like man i'm talking a lot i'm
drained i'm out of it
uh
and i and i hated that feeling because i
don't i don't want to have that when i
come here i don't want to have i don't
want to deliver that and uh
he i
texted him the next morning i said hey
man can we can we talk
say i need i need to talk to you about
some things and i just told him straight
up because i knew something was up
i knew something he goes he goes i just
know you you like we go on the road
together
and
you know you're such a positive guy and
you're so on it
and uh
and happy
uh because i could just tell something
was off and so yeah i just told him
basically you know i
just want to do this i want to narrow it
down to just
you know really focusing on the things
that i want to focus on i'm excited
about
my career and what i'm doing
uh with stand-up comedy this
uh my band
um
all the above any anything and
everything that i've been doing
that like that's outside of
you know
being on fighter in the kid and stuff
i'm just excited about
yeah yeah like i said i had a great time
on a show there i mean it's done a lot
for me done a lot
done done a lot of great things for me
you know and been able to give me
you know a solid platform nice people
uh saying nice things to me
you know
even i even think that i appreciate the
people that hated me
you know thanks for hating me
that's that's a you know
look at this is haters will say
no it is what's what's funny about um
about going into that show
i knew
i was like i'm gonna get hate
because when you think about it i don't
know if you think about in this terms
but i think about it in these terms
whenever
there's a band you like
and then one member
leaves
and this new member comes
everybody's weird about that new member
and everyone's going to say something
about how they don't like that new
member because they missed the old
member because they had a connection
with that member
now think about me
coming in
for brian
you guys are kind of opposite no polar
opposite
skin tone and all
teeth hair
style
all of it you have good teeth good hair
good style yep and then there's brian
and then there's brian he's sandals and
he's great and he's very old turtleneck
yeah
and that's fine and that's fine we're
exactly 20 years apart
is that right he's yeah he's born 19 uh
january 26th 42 because he's 16.
he's he's just trying to do the most
no he uh he's january 26 1967. i'm
january 23rd 1987.
26th
26th meatball i'll throw a [ __ ]
meatball at you meatball
um
but yeah i was like of course people are
gonna hate me
people are gonna hate me especially
because i feel like in the podcasting
world not even feel it is
people in the pa people that are really
into the podcasting world are die-hard
fans
almost cult-like
almost called like fans fans would you
say yeah yeah
so this cult of chappelle's world better
be the biggest cult i've ever seen
in my life
what needs to say yes i knew
walking into it
i kind of just had to take it
you know i wasn't trying to take
anyone's spot or take anyone's anything
of that nature
it's just it's not mine
but i had to understand going into this
you're gonna get some hate you're gonna
get some messages
here's some messages
some really mean messages
[Laughter]
don't be mean to chappelle yeah i mean
it happens
people but i i don't take offense to
people
being mean to me because i'm like
at the end of the day they really don't
know who i am right
so so what they say about me isn't
of accuracy
and luckily
my weird ass journal so damn much and
just learning about myself all the damn
time or just
always doing anything and everything i
can to understand
my growth and who i am and what what i
feel
that when people talk [ __ ] about me it
doesn't really
i'm like okay
all right let's take a break from this
episode to talk about happy hippo one of
the best kratoms in the game right now
uh use kratom to fire up my brain for
any shows uh whether it's comedy shows
or performing with my band podcast it's
like a limitless pill it's a great
focused product one of the best uh best
part is that it's all natural okay so
nothing crazy going through your body
that you don't want to want to go
through there even though you guys do a
lot of crazy crazy things already but
anyways visit happyhippos.com
and use promo code thick boy for 20 off
and that's for life you can use that
code as many times as you want once
again that's happy hippo herbals.com
and use promo code thick boy for 20 off
also people been talking [ __ ] about me
since i was a kid
really
yes
yes i don't see why i got made fun of
more
for being uh
a black dude that listens to punk rock
than a cheerleader
that's so stupid isn't it crazy who
cares what the [ __ ] you listen to what'd
you say who cares what you listen to no
just let me be myself
let me be myself
get out of my room get out of my room
let me be myself
[Laughter]
that's good i'm glad i'm happy for you i
think uh it gives you more of an
opportunity to have a more focused
approach on this show yeah you're still
doing cats after dark yeah like you're
you're still going to be doing a bunch
of podcasts just now you don't have
as much on your plate spreading yourself
yeah then be able to like focus on yeah
i'm just excited to really stand as an
individual yeah that's what that's what
i'm excited about you know
i mean
some people may think it's crazy
for me leaving but i'm like i don't
[ __ ]
[Music]
flipping my hair back
then i had a great weekend
uh last
week weekend i went to uh it was like i
took a week off from just doing shows
and
stand up because i've been doing a lot
of it and i like when i'm able to do so
and just do something else that i love
as well
and
i went to
so toby and his band h2o they had some
shows with madball
um
in new jersey and
pawtucket rhode island
uh i think that's how you pronounce that
pawtucket he could look at him raise up
yeah
it's it's pawtucket
there's no w
paw attack it it's spelled
pawtc
how did they say it out there
no no they did with the accent
what
they do add a w in there you hear it
when they say with the accent they don't
say like look you said
it like oh i did say pawtucket
look how it
spelled so weird
we'll give paw tuck i'm not supposed to
look how it's spelled oh yeah
i got to type it
[ __ ]
apple i chuck it why talk it hey man
pawtucket
uh
oh wow that's crazy in the news of
pawtucket did you see that no what did
it say uh police arrest
and deadly pawtucket shooting okay is
that commonplace for pitch socket uh
yeah i was telling chappelle it's the
most white trash like scummiest part of
rhode island to really be in hey don't
you dare speak of pawtucket like that i
had a great time there took it's great
have you been to the junk and donuts in
particular yeah
i would take it i would take a vacation
to pawtucket
you wouldn't anyways uh if you do then
you need help okay
anyways so anyways yeah h2o madball
and they were doing uh
uh running
they did two shows new jersey pawtucket
and
mad ball and
h2o
also had this band
called hazen street was like their side
project that they did
um
and it had dave kennedy from angels and
airwaves as on the guitar
uh mackie
from uh chrome mags
og bad
he was in bad brains for a second
amongst uh many other
stuff but they they did this record back
in 2004
uh of hazel street oh actually hey i'm
wearing a sweater
but anyways hazen street so they were
doing some shows and it was it was nice
to get away and nice to like not have to
think about comedy or podcasting or
anything just to step aside for a second
and uh
man i love going out and being a groupie
is it a groupie that i am
following a band on tour well i ain't
following them i was riding you know in
the bus with them so i was like oh man
cool chappelle's world anyways
dude it was it was a lot of fun man i i
didn't have to think about anything
crazy or what what i had to do the next
day and just kind of just floated around
and
embraced uh the shows and i got to see
phenomenal drumming
this weekend a lot of great drumming
i i got some great footage of course i
got to start off with toby's son max
he's 19 years old and the kid has been
killing it man and he's
he's just amazing it's dope to watch him
progress and when he first
started drumming for
the band
uh
obviously a little nervous but now he's
got this flow of rhythm and he gives
this energy to
h2o that's like this like because he
hits the [ __ ] those goddamn drums but
watch him uh this i think this is a song
singing before watch them hit this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so clean
get it max
so whenever i'm on the road with them
basically i'll i'll act as max's drum
tech
uh i can't play the drums i can play a
beat
okay
uh
i'm gonna hate for the day when he asks
me to
do the you know like when you go to a
concert
and then they're like all right kick
drum dude
i'm going to hate when he asked me to do
that more because because i would be
terrified
even though it's just like snare you
just hit it
and then but the thing is what they do
after they go okay play the full set
like wait like like you know
so they could have heard me no thank you
i'm like no no we're good those are
those are those are fine oh everything
just they all work
individually so i'm guessing
i trust you sound guy i trust you but uh
his favorite drummer and
it's mackie and mackie has helped uh max
out and learn some stuff i think i want
to say macky has helped him out and
travis barker has helped him out uh
toby's
toby's got a lot of friends but macky
plays in such a dope way he's got this
uh
he's a jazz drum like i think he's jazz
drummer but he can play hardcore and he
can play anything and he adds his jazz
flare
to it in such a dope way and watch how
crisp he
is and then
and what's cute about this video is max
max eventually comes and sits down
and uh look at him
[Music]
he loves mackie
[Music]
but see how he plays his snare kind of
slanted a little bit
it's kind of yeah you can't really tell
in that video but he plays his snare up
kind of high
and down at an angle to get that
rim pop boom
but it's just so like crisp and just
[Music]
see how he
yeah think about that bro i wish i could
do that
but it was it was it was fun shows
anyways mackie is amazing and then also
the drummer of mad ball
[ __ ]
rips uh mike i don't know how to [ __ ]
pronounce his last uh last name it's
like just stain
just staying sustained
it's just no just stain i'll figure it
but anyways even him too he [ __ ] used
to drum for a
metal band called unearth
[Music]
jizz
[Music]
watch him hit it right here ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it was fun i was i was being groupie
i was groupied the [ __ ] out man
oh that are you pulling up that picture
so this picture this was a magical
moment for me magic magical moment for
for for
uh big ass punk ass chappelle lacy over
here i got to uh
so h2o i've done this song [ __ ] many
times with them but anyways the origin
the original part of the songs it's
h2o's guilty by association and the last
30 seconds of the song
is guest vocals and it's from freddie
madball from lead singer of mad ball who
i idolize a lot and uh
he
it's his part of the song and i told i
pulled him from backstage i said hey
they're about to do guilty
you know and max requested you and max
max has been around these dudes since he
was a kid so he loves all them they're
like his uncles to him and i said max
requested you to do it and he goes no
you do it because
he's seen me do it i said no no no no no
he wants you to do it you do it he goes
all right do it with me and i was like
i thought she never asked but it was
such a cool moment that's cool i mean
listen and i say this and i say it and i
say it again i always geek out
over musicians musicians
like meeting musicians and all that
stuff is the one thing i could i don't
geek out over meeting
actors if i met didn't say it'll be a
different story uh if i met eddie murphy
be different sorry but if i met oh i did
meet val kilmer
but anyways
but when it comes to musicians
there's just this level of connection
that i have and what i feel with
musicians it's like the people with
podcasting there there goes
it's like that people that love
podcasting love these podcasters like
tim dillon uh shows like that these
dudes that have the rogan they have
these cult followings all these
podcasters that's how i feel
about
when i'm around these musicians and so
uh i got to sing that part
with freddy
uh both nights both nights actually if
you go to my instagram and go to my
story because um
oh damn okay
that's the girl from um squid game
oh that is oh that is her yeah
i like her what is this from the
her name's huey
hoey
i don't know oh whatever all right
uni
yeah whatever
no go to my story ah
hit next oh yeah i'll be in san diego
this weekend
may 6th and 7th my drop comedy club uh
that's me look at look at me
is that groupie what do you call that
it's a group roadie roadie
thank you
yeah look at me looking like a roadie
yeah uh the next video but this moment
right here
it was cool uh
[Music]
that was this morning yeah that was his
warning yeah i had to roll up on his ass
because he was talking [ __ ] in text this
morning oh my god trying to call me ugh
i said right i see you on the freeway
homie
get your ass beat
anyways
uh
very special moment
for me to be able to be a part of that
it was cool watching those bands play
together because they've been homies
for for
decades or whatever i don't know how
many decades but you know whatever
they've been they've been friends and
it's such a solid combo because h2o and
madbar are completely different
bands obviously the foundation of both
of them is hardcore but they're
different mad like because i watch them
both play obviously
when h2o goes up it's like this like
yeah you know like if you were smiling
when bad ball gets on stage it's like
[ __ ]
yeah i mean they're not called happy
ball
[Laughter]
give this guy a raise
give him a [ __ ] also not a bad band
name happy ball happy ball maybe that
should be my best day yeah happy ball
yeah
since i'm such a big mad ball fan yeah
happy ball is my advantage
i like it the first the first uh album
cover is gonna be a bunny
just playing with a carrot or something
i don't know because that's a cute thing
it's always cute when bunnies are eating
and squirrels are eating but isn't that
a
like a white rabbit isn't that a drug
reference is that a what reference drug
white rabbit no white pony
let's look it up so get up
white rabbit i'm pretty sure isn't that
because that's uh
yeah it's
yeah yeah
you don't know that song you know one
pill makes you larger
the jefferson airplane is the dude
that's the flute right
is it jefferson airplane
yeah that yeah they got a flute right
there
homie has a i thought it was a dude that
had a flute it looks like a
female
yeah that does uh
i can't white rabbit's about about drugs
yeah bro or just doing drugs in general
i'm not sure
white rabbit urban dictionary oh what
okay
let's try that
that's that's what it may be
i think they're referencing alice in
wonderland
okay
one of them yeah psychedelic drugs like
lsd
there was listen there was another
definition that i saw pop up
zoom in i want to make sure i'm reading
this right you know me
shitty eyes lacy no no scroll up
it's when a white man sticks his penis
in between his legs it looks like a
rabbit is coming out of his ass hey pete
you want to see a white rabbit yeah cool
that's what meatball was doing in the
car and this morning that's what he was
trying to do
he was trying to i don't trust you
man from pawtucket i don't trust you
i don't trust meatball oh god one of
your own sticks his penis between his
legs i thought that was a mangina yeah
yeah that's what i thought i never
yeah what kind of white rabbit is that
from like well maybe maybe that's what
they called it in the 70s looks like he
had a rabbit coming out of his ass hey
pete
hey pete you want to see a white rabbit
dude
so
i think i discovered this while i was in
austin
austin texas
hey you ever been austin oh yeah it's a
new place like
uh i was in austin texas and
what do i do the most everybody
read journal so
and i was journaling and the song i
always journal to
is i wonder
by uh kanye west
and so
it just
one of those songs that helps me out
bring out my feels and i leave it on
repeat and it just
lets me like
pushes i don't know just pulls a lot out
of me because
it's a song that i always think about
that you know
during this weird period of time in my
life when that song came out i think
i've explained this before but it was
that
i thought about how i was
not living with my family not seeing my
siblings not seeing my mom
and i was you know living with my
adopted folks
at the time and i think
that was when it like really hit me that
i
wasn't with my
you know where i came from or whatever
um so that song you know has a very very
very very special place
in my heart
now i went back and i this is a
beautiful thing about hip-hop
that i love
sampling
hey
hey let's take a song that was already
made do some weird [ __ ] with it make it
yeah
new song new song so kai sampled it from
an artist
that i just recently discovered and
when i discovered this artist i was like
this is one of the most underrated
musicians i think i've ever
took the time to learn about and i'm not
the only one that says that because i
felt it when i was looking at his stuff
his name is laby
i don't know how to panet no no
yeah you spelled it completely wrong
uh you just gotta get something out
there and like google clean it up google
will be like i know i know what you're
trying to say
google must be exhausted from
[ __ ] that can't speak like me
yeah google's like again
just
figure it out man google is [ __ ]
exhausted google does too many podcasts
google needs to [ __ ] yeah um
anyways he's from um
uh
london he's british
british
but the song that kanye sampled is
called my song
right
and now that song has become my
song i journal to
the original song
pull up the lyrics
to my song
i was sold at the the beginning because
i was like it's such a beautiful
sample i was like i should just i don't
know why i've just now taken the time to
learn where it comes from
but
just the first lyrics alone first set of
lyrics alone
this is my song and no one can take it
away
that's like that's like i don't know to
me that
and as i'm journaling this it's it to me
it's saying like this is my story
knowing no one can take it away no one
can define it no one could do anything
with it but only i can
and it just [ __ ]
hits are you reading the lyrics bro
you're gonna cry when you hear that when
you actually hear the song i wish we
could play it on here but obviously
copyright so we're not gonna do that i
don't know
maybe when we get like some cool thing
with spotify
we'll uh
they'll let us use some songs and [ __ ]
uh but anyways
but this is not the only song that's
beautiful about him and kanye's not the
only rapper to sample him
you ready for this yes
here's another sample hit me
hi my name is uh my name is who my name
is
and this is the guitar part
that's where it says
that's lavi
wow that's uh lavish siffrey
safree
gosh i can't i need to learn how to say
his name but i started learning about
this artist and it took a little deep
dive
on them and there's not many i searched
on youtube there's not too many
interviews on him but the stuff that the
interview that i've watched
he speaks so intelligently
about
his work and what he does
and just seems like a guy that's so
understanding of himself
and
has a true love
for the work that he does and those are
the people i'm always
super intrigued by and want to learn
more from he has a he kind of has a sad
sad story um he's a gay man
okay
he likes dudes
let him have that okay
but uh
both of his partners
that he that he's
had long-term relationships with both of
them
had passed away so the first one i think
he
his first husband had passed away and
his second husband had passed away but
um
he i don't know man i i just
there's just so much to this dude
meanwhile i don't know how how many
people
know about them if you if you know about
la if you or have known about him
i don't know leave a comment or
something and
tell me everything that you know
because uh
i'm trying to find more to really
understand but what's dope
i was looking at his albums and the one
thing i always look for
is writers
who's
he writes all his own [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] all songs written and
performed by him
they don't make them like that anymore
i mean there are people that do
but
and he's really [ __ ] good
he's got bad ass hits and and there's
quite a few people that have covered his
songs that i didn't realize uh that one
band with the younger kids they're uh
they sound kind of like 70s classic rock
uh
greta
grete of vampire oh yeah yeah they've
covered a song by him um
anyways lots of people have covered
songs right
i can't remember by the way
it's all such recent
uh phonetic oh yeah so it's lovey ziffra
oh libby lobby
yeah
beautiful [ __ ] name beautiful [ __ ]
artist
um
learn more about this dude listen to his
[ __ ] he's super
super underrated an amazing guitar
player
amazing at piano
i just i don't know i
i just appreciate ever
starting to really appreciate this dude
yeah he's made quite a few albums i
don't
yeah but the one the crying laughing
uh
that album
that's like one of his his dope ones
that uh
yeah this one right here this one has
the the song that kanye had sampled
on it and then uh the other album go
back or
[Music]
remember my song 19 that one that came
out in 1975 so the song is uh that
eminem or dr dre has sample for the
eminem hi my name is is the i got the
that song beautiful song and jay-z also
sampled that song i want to say the song
the streets of the streets are watching
i think it's what uh jay-z
has sampled but man i i don't know i um
based off that little interview i love
people that are kind of these mysteries
he's like a mystery
and all you could do is just read
what online the [ __ ] about him but
man i'm a fan i'm glad i [ __ ] took a
deep dive back seems like there needs to
be like a documentary about him yeah
he's super underrated but his songs are
so beautiful
and i don't just
i don't know i love hearing people
hearing people explain
it seems like he lets his music just
talk for him
and he kind of just chills
in the back the way he wants to chill
i love those kind of people that's how i
feel about kendrick lamar like i feel
like kendrick lamar does a lot of
interviews or
you know really talks much i mean he
speaks of being an introvert in his
songs but
i feel like he's one of those artists
whose music hits so big but meanwhile
he's just kind of
you know back there in his corner just
chilling i love people like that let the
work speak for itself yeah
can i do that no i can't because i do a
podcast right
so it makes it kind of difficult
to be able to do
that kind of thing
maybe that's why you're drawn to it yeah
it's like you know when you know when i
did the joke
about my adoptive folks i thought back
to a time
you know where
i was like i'm sitting in the kitchen
and i looked at them and i go wow
one day i'm gonna be a comedian i'll
make a joke about them powerful and then
here we are and it just kind of
created itself
along the way
i learned that at juilliard
it always circles i love saying when i
went to juilliard and i never went to
juilliard but uh
nah dope dope artist top artist i
actually i'll put
we'll do a couple of his songs on the
the playlist after
yeah uh oh yeah i did a don't tell set
that's out online
uh
for don't tell comedy don't don't tell
comedy is uh
these secret shows
that uh
they don't tell you to line up
don't tell uh
i see i didn't understand what the don't
tell component was yeah but it's they
don't tell you
that's
funny yeah anyways
look at me just [ __ ]
bouncing around so big what am i doing
lose weight chappelle
i am i'm doing sprints but uh
anyways so
i think
they've just taken this format and don't
tell us just want to want to showcase
comedians that aren't necessarily as
well known or you know not are up and
coming uh you know comedians because
there's a lot of really good comedians
out there that don't necessarily have
the strongest platforms to be put out
there the way they are and with these
don't tell shows they're always really
good they're secret shows
they do them all over california i want
to say they do them in texas
uh on the east coast as well but anyways
so you can go to don't tell comedy
youtube page to see my set and just type
in chapelle ac with that and then also
if you ever want to go to a don't tell
show
you just go to don't tell comedy.com or
something like that and then they always
have shows in your area and they and
they don't they don't drop the location
of the show until
12 p.m the day of the show that day oh
that's cool so it's kind of like this
cool mystery yeah like they call it like
a speakeasy series yeah yeah that's cool
yeah it's cool it's really really cool
it's a small small room but that room i
want to say set like
maybe 100 people but it was it was nice
tight very intimate cool
jazz vibe type deal but but it was i
don't know it was it was it was fun and
uh i don't have that that's the most
recent set i have out there and people
are always asking about my comedy and
the last uh
set i did that was actually posted
online was from 2019 when i did um
comedy comedy central's cluster fest so
that that was the last [ __ ] thing
that i had uh posted
but
um yes so that said is online appreciate
it if you watched it
and uh
don't don't take my joke serious
there's you know uh you've heard me do
the joke about my adopted folks right um
yeah i mean i saw one comment because
like it
they did a collab with me like the
[ __ ] instagram thing technology but
uh so i see what comments pop up
and they posted just to click the reel a
reel of me talking doing the joke about
my adopted folks which is just a small
part of the vid all those bits that i
did on the don't tell
um
that set are all like very condensed
parts of the bench there's more to the
bits
anyways
someone goes
man these people try to give you a
second chance
super literally
oh they took
the joke so
literal
they're like you're a toxic person
you just don't get it dude it is it's
insane
meanwhile
and i i it's it's it's
why would i argue that
it'd be insane for me to go
hey man who the [ __ ] do you think you
are because it's because they already
have a set in their minds yeah that i'm
a toxic person
uh but if you want to know more about me
come to a show when i'm in your city
yeah
just learn about me before you
you know
and and don't judge me off a reel of it
but anyways [ __ ] it who cares and it's a
joke that's the only defense like if you
haven't that's what i'm saying
when you're standing up on this yeah
yeah do i have to go hey these are not
real these are jokes if you don't get
that you're an idiot yeah
that's like watching that enough i'm
putting my foot down oh it's if you're
calling chappelle toxic
because you don't get that it's a joke
and you're being literal you're stupid
and shut up
all right let's do a playlist let's do a
playlist add it up to here casey's had
it up to here with you folks and
taking this [ __ ] the wrong way yeah i
don't like when uh people are mean to
you let's do a playlist
okay
uh we'll start off with laby
labby uh
ah man i just did it he just did it too
you know i thought i thought you were
gonna have the yeah yep
so 1b
anyways you know what casey i know what
i know the songs i know how to find them
so you're spelling i'm not going to
comment on on anymore
uh we'll do lavish sifri and we'll do my
song the original
uh to the kanye sample and then we'll do
um
uh his other song uh the other song the
one that
dr dre
had sampled i got the
um
let's make this a nice smooth playlist
then oh let's let's take it let's take
it on the ride let's do marvin gaye
troubleman
i wish it would rain suit temptations i
wish i wish it would rain
i feel like that sometimes here in los
angeles
[Laughter]
wake up los angeles it's casey garrity
every time it rains i go but we need it
we need it we do need it we need it i
actually enjoy the rain i actually don't
mind at all
we'll do the next song i saw tup
thumping
now
yeah trouble wamba we'll do it
it doesn't really fit man this is the
first time i might have to veto
it's cause it popped up on my on my
phone
uh
who else should we go with that
we'll go with the
four tops let's go with ain't no woman
are you really keeping chumbawamba in
there
i mean [ __ ] you got to mix it up a
little bit
um
we'll go with the spinners
it's a shame
we'll go with another spinner song
what's that other one oh could uh
could it be i'm falling in love yeah
could it be i'm falling in love that's a
great one oh actually we'll add
another marvin gaye
heard it through the grapevine
you know what it is i know why i'm
making this list
i was watching you ever seen a movie
four brothers
yes
uh with mark wahlberg tyrese and uh
andre 3000 and the whole the pretty much
that whole soundtrack is like a lot of
these songs yeah
except trump chamber one but they didn't
really add that to the the credits maybe
it was jumbo
the closing credits
we'll be seeing it
hold on let me look at that [ __ ]
actually
four brothers
they have a jefferson airplane song on
there hey pete
somebody to love mike rabbit
jefferson airplane somebody love we'll
do that one
uh would you say somebody to love
yeah oh actually i want to do more oh
we'll do um hard times by baby huey
we'll close it with that
nope
other way there you go
e-u e-y e-y
so sometimes it's so simple it's right
there
hard times that'll be the place that
playlist for this week that looks like a
good one yeah i mean honestly i think
you could lose
what'd you say i think you could lose
chumbawamba but
you know should we take it off no no i'm
just i don't
we went this far with it
um thank you guys for tuning in uh
man if you were a listener of fighter
and the kid and you know
and you liked me on there and
you want to transition over here that's
cool thank you uh that i appreciate the
love
if you do uh if you hated me
um you might like me over here i don't
know
that's perfect
give it a go hey move this way move the
needle over here yeah give this version
of give this version
of me a try
see what you think if you hate it hey
i can hey i can handle hate
it's fine no i don't i get it if you
hate it
just zip it if you hate just hey zip it
the lip zip it zip it i love when
teachers used to say that to me hey
chappelle zip it i'm like all right cool
uh but man thanks thanks for tuning in
to this uh i want i want this to really
grow and i'm glad i'm able to focus on
it and put all my um
all my love into uh
chappelle's world now and uh for those
that have been supporting
uh thanks for continuing to listen and
thanks for the people that really enjoy
the playlist because every time i go out
and do shows people are always like yo i
love your playlist i'm like oh so it's
cool yeah so people are actually really
receptive to the playlist and that means
a lot and then uh
um
what else oh i got tour dates yes please
come see me actually this weekend
uh friday and saturday may 6th and 7th
grand opening of a new comedy club in
san diego called mic drop comedy club uh
i will be there both nights and white
mike who you've seen on that podcast
he's actually done back to back episodes
first guest to ever do that
um he will be in the house okay and then
may 12th i'll be doing one nighter in
the hometown of phoenix at stand-up live
yo if you don't show up
if in my hometown if you
[Music]
don't show up
it is it is
it is on and then uh june 24th and 25th
i'll be in east providence rhode island
uh which pawtucket is not too far from
so come up from pawtucket and i'll be at
the comedy connection june 24th and 25th
all those tickets at
get those chapellelacey.com
and i'll see you this weekend san diego